layna
starts off this hour in Little Rock
Arkansas hey Lena welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show how are you doing today
better than I deserve how can I help
I have a question for you I have
listened for a long time and I've never
heard this question asked so I figured
I'd have to ask you myself
we argue with our first baby in July and
we are currently on baby step 3 being me
although we don't own a house we kind of
a house that we have a mortgage on and
we are working to get back up to our six
months emergency fund after we had to
buy a new AC and heater system okay and
so we're just a few thousand dollars
away from that so we'll be doing step
four next doing that right but what I'm
wondering for our baby that's due in
July do you believe in higher education
leavers on college degrees I just don't
necessarily know what that's going to
look like in 18 years and so I would
like to save for college with higher
education but I want to know if there is
a different type of savings account that
you would use other than an ESA that is
only limited to college does that make
sense yeah no there isn't because the
only one that grows tax-free is the say
or the 529 they're basically a wrong i
right so here's your numbers okay if you
put in two thousand dollars a year for
18 years you put in thirty six thousand
dollars if that grows at a typical
mutual fund rate eighteen years later
that 36 thousand will have grown to over
a hundred and twenty eight so you have
roughly a hundred thousand dollars worth
of growth in that account that is going
to be taxable if it's in a different
kind of account and so this is a twenty
five or thirty thousand dollar
discussion we're having so I'm gonna
take that risk I don't know what college
is going to look like in eighteen years
either
I sure hope it is different because
guaranteed a federally insured student
loans have been done away with I think
we ought to stop guaranteeing loans for
students because it's a wrong call it's
it's hurt more people than it's helped
and the government should get out of the
business of hurting its own people and
so anyway that's just an opinion but I
don't know what's going to happen I know
that there's a 1.6 trillion dollar
problem on the horizon that somehow is
going to be addressed so but all of that
to say I suspect that let's say let's
say Elizabeth Warren became King Queen
okay if she became Queen and just waved
her wand and did away with college cost
to the individual and the government was
going to raise taxes to end pay for
college which is her wish okay
socialized college which i think would
be a disaster but that's what she wants
to do so let's just say that that
happened okay and you had the money in
this account I suspect part of the
legislation for changing our whole world
would involve freeing up that money for
you I don't think they're suddenly going
to penalize you because you saved for
college I don't know they might they're
liberals you never know but it's not
it's kind of you know brain disease so I
don't know but the we'll see what would
happen but you know the I'm gonna save
for college with what I know with what's
in front of me right now if I'm in your
shoes I've got six grand babies under
the age of five
all of them have es A's thank you so
that's you know because I don't know I'm
with you I don't know what's gonna
happen I think there's you know there's
crap on the horizon without a doubt if
something's gonna change because we got
too big a problem to not address it it's
gonna cave in on itself if they don't
address it so they're gonna have to
address it but the policy wants that be
what they're going to do with us regular
people who knows but in the meantime the
ESA I'm gonna load that sucker up or the
529 in the 529
you only do the kind where you control
your investment options not where
they're Auto controlled for you and it's
not prepaid college it's saving for
college in mutual funds that you select
and they don't get moved unless you move
them that's the proper kind of 529 and
that's all you can do with an ESA so
awesomeness